il est huit heures du matin c'est
l'heure de se rendre aux champs
ghislaine exploitant agricole dans une
petite ville du sud-ouest donne ses
instructions aux ouvriers par mesure de
précaution contre locaux vides 19
tout le monde se lave les mains et
enfile une paire de gants avant de
commencer un grand nombre de
professionnels ont utilisé leur droit de
retrait face à la menace sanitaire pour
la récolte du colza
ghislaine et son mari peuvent compter
sur la générosité d'une dizaine
d'habitants venus travailler
bénévolement
normalement chaque année on a rien il ya
une équipe de femmes qui kiffe et tout
le secteur et donc elle parce que j'ai
plusieurs exploitants et dès cette année
du coup avec le collier d'elles elles
ont préféré opter pour le pour le pour
le droit de retrait donc ce qui fait que
sur le coup ça a été compliqué pour nous
on s'est dit comment est ce qu'on va
faire parce que si on épure pas tout
simplement ses droits y est j'en ai
perdu elle a récolté perdu et en faisant
notre marché des amis se sont proposés
pour venir nous aider et on s'est
retrouvé avec des personnes parce que
toutes les personnes qui étaient autour
sont venus étudier spontanément en ce
qui concerne la récolte des fraises
celle ci s'opère à effectif réduit mais
sans problème les ouvriers habituel de
nationalité bulgare sont restés coincés
au village en raison du confinement
ce n'est pas le cas de bogdan qui a
réussi à se libérer
chaque année nous rabâcher les fraises
des fruits ramassés du service abricots
les raisins légumes et des fruits
ramassés
j'ai trouvé de notre producteur et
travaillé longtemps les connaît notre
travail contentant d'un autre producteur
[Musique]
les bénévoles donnent de leur temps pour
aider les exploitants plus que jamais
déstabilisé par la crise du coronavirus
marianne est étudiante en biologie à
cause du comité 19 elle se retrouve sans
stage elle a donc décidé de prêter main
forte aux agriculteurs une occasion de
mettre en pratique ses connaissances et
de s'occuper pendant le confinement
je me suis retrouvé à faire des cours en
ligne
mais j'avais du temps livre et je me
suis dit que c'est l'occasion de deux le
mettre en pratique donc chez les du sac
ça me permettez moi de travailler
d'occuper le montant est de les aider
donc j'ai postulé naturellement je les
ai appelés ils m'ont recontacté quelques
jours après pour me dire que c'était ok
et voilà donc là c'est la quatrième
semaine où je travaille
conséquence de la crise sanitaire pour
le monde agricole des phénomène de
surconsommation et de surproduction ont
vu le jour
de quoi espérer peut-être prochainement
une redynamisation pour une filière en
proie à d'importantes difficultés depuis
plusieurs années et 10